i don't think you could have selected
two finer actresses in
jenna and in maddie i mean for both of
you ladies
this movie we've got grief trauma
uh relationships drugs when the both of
you
read the script were there any scenes
that you were like
i think we're going to need to sit down
and have some conversations about how
we're going to approach this
me and jenna hung out before we started
and i think we both and i don't know if
megan knows this but we were both really
nervous to film
uh kind of like the drunk scenes i think
we're both pretty mellow for the most
part in real life
but we we got there we were crazy on set
but like we were so nervous
or at least i was really nervous about
that i was really nervous about that and
we had that conversation on set with
megan too and megan was
you know saying you could be crazier
with it even if you want to
you know like you could walk like this
you could trip
you know whatever so i'm kind of falling
into it like okay whatever
the thing i felt the worst about was
telling maddie i was like hey i need you
to learn how to
roll joints really well but i was like
how do i ask her
to like learn how to do that because
originally this scene was supposed to be
that she was like
so good at it and then when i started
filming it what you saw is actually like
the first take when she actually did it
because
they were both so nervous and fumbling
and i was as i was watching it happen in
real time i was like this is so much
better than maddie being amazing at it
it's just this like
hilarious awkwardness that they're doing
and so we ended up using that take which
i think is so much better but she did
learn how to roll them using fake wow i
think also
i was very lucky to have jenna with me
and i think we kind of just fed off each
other's energy and
as the especially like when it's the
montage of us kind of drunk in the
street it's kind of very much just like
as the night was going on we were just
more and more crazy we were drinking
like slurpees we had like candy so we
were just like on a sugar rush
so it definitely helps the process i
think i think something that the fallout
does really wonderfully is
it's an accurate depiction of of kids in
high school and
we all experience at least i know i
certainly did insecurities and
you have perceptions of other people and
you don't realize that
you know you think it's a and it's
actually b are there insecurities that
you have
um that you either used to struggle with
or you still currently do and how do you
how do you balance it all yeah i think
especially
our generation with social media and all
of that it's really easy to compare
yourself
to to everyone i i have a really
hard time with that it doesn't really go
away like it's something that you kind
of carry but
um especially in your teenage years i
feel like it's just like
heavily at the forefront of most
conversations or
experiences and how how is your
relationship with social media right now
i don't love social media uh
i think i don't know i think it used to
be super fun and like relaxed and just
like
you go on to see what your friends are
doing or what like a drink they're
drinking that day like it was very
very light-hearted and it's become kind
of like a toxic place but i try to look
at it
for the good yeah
i i try to like my my explore page i've
kind of made it to what like it's uh
curated to what i want to look at so
like
art makeup dance stuff like that
maddie i got to spend a little bit of
time with your mom a couple years ago on
the set of
one of your sister's music video shoots
and your family's just wonderful are
there any scenes in this movie
that you are giving friends and family
like a polite courtesy heads-up
i'd prefer if you did this during this
scene
yeah i mean i i feel uncomfortable if my
mom watches me kiss someone so that's
probably
the one and my sister felt she she
couldn't watch
uh so that was that you tried to show it
to your sister
i i they they saw the movie
but they my sister had a really hard
time apparently i don't know why
i don't know why it's like just leave
the details out
like the art you did an amazing job
you're both so talented but i i totally
appreciate you know
maybe maybe you could not mention the
part where i'm kissing somebody yeah
you don't even need to wear makeup sorry
what
i just said you don't even need to wear
makeup
all right maddie for you it's been
really wonderful i i grew up watching
you on television and seeing you
transition so beautifully into your work
as an actress
what has that been like i'm so lucky
that i've
been able to transition into acting and
i definitely think
dancing for that obviously i discovered
that i loved it through dancing just
because i was constantly playing a
character
in whatever performance i was doing so
it was a really
nice transition but i'm still so new and
still like
such a beginner so that's why i'm so
honored to be in this movie alongside
jenna and everyone else just because i'm
like i don't feel like i should be here
but
you do you do thank you but just um
just learning from megan and jenna
i'm so inspired and i've learned so much
by just watching them on set
and i'm so excited to carry that
knowledge that i've learned
for whatever comes next and i hope to
continue acting and
yeah is there a bucket list role
or a project that you like pie in the
sky would love to be a part of
i think it's pretty insane that i grew
up watching
west side story and i get to be in the
remake in just a little part like that
was kind of like uh
what is happening what is my life uh so
that was really cool just to be a part
of such um
an iconic dance film it's really cool